I'M KIDDING.
PRESIDENT BIDEN FINALLY UNITING
THE COUNTRY AND AGREEMENT ROUND
ONE NOTION: THE ECONOMY TOTALLY
STINKS.
A MAJORITY OF AMERICANS
DISAPPROVE OF BIDEN ON NEARLY
EVERY KEY ECONOMIC CONCERN.
37% APPROVE OF HIS HANDLING OF
THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND HAS
WORSE NUMBERS ON ISSUES LIKE GAS
PRICES AND INFLATION.
NEARLY 80% OF AMERICANS SAY THE
ECONOMY IS IN EXTREMELY OR VERY
IMPORTANT FACTOR IN HOW THEY
WILL VOTE.
THE MEDIA TRYING TO WARN
DEMOCRATS OF WHAT'S TO COME.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN IS A SERIOUS
DRAG ON DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES
NATIONWIDE.
HE IS BADLY UNDERWATER ON ALL
THE TOP ISSUES INCLUDING THE BIG
ONES.
INFLATION, GAS PRICES.
LESS THAN 30% APPROVAL RATING ON
THE ISSUES WE ARE TOLD BY VOTERS
ARE DOMINATING THEIR STATE OF
MIND.
>> Greg: GAS PRICES HIT A
STAGGERING RECORD HIGH AT $4.86
A GALLON, DOUBLING SINCE BIDEN'S
PRESIDENCY BEGAN.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS HAVING NO
PROBLEM PASSING THE BLAME ON
THEIR ECONOMIC WOES.
>> THE PRICE OF GASOLINE IS NOT
SET BY A DIAL IN THE OVAL OFFICE
AND WHEN AN OIL COMPANY IS
DECIDING OUR BY OUR HOW MUCH TO
CHARGE YOU FOR A GALLON OF GAS,
THEY ARE NOT CALLING THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ASK WHAT THEY
SHOULD DO.
THEY ARE DOING IT BASED ON THEIR
GOAL OF MAXIMIZING THEIR
PROFITS.
>> GAS PRICES ARE UP $1.40 A
GALLON SINCE PUTIN MOVED TROOPS
INTO UKRAINE.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED
WHEN PUTIN STARTED AMASSING
TROOPS ON THE BORDER WITH
RUSSIA, THE PRICE OF GAS HAS
INCREASED BY $1.51.
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO UP AND
WELCOME BACK, DANA.
YOU WERE MISSED.
>> Dana: I WONDERED IF PEOPLE
WOULD NOTICE.
>> Greg: IT WAS PRETTY AWFUL
WHAT YOU SAID AND DID.
ENTER RETWEET IT WAS DISGUSTING.
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU.
LAST WEEK.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS WE DON'T
HAVE A SWITCH TO TURN OUR BABY
FORMULA.
IN THIS CASE IT'S MAYOR PETE
SAYING THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
DIAL.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS NO
MAGIC FORMULA BUT YOU'RE IN
CHARGE SO WHAT THE HELL ARE YOU
DOING?
>> Dana: THERE IS THIS
PATTERN.
THEY MISSED THE PROBLEM OR THEY
MISDIAGNOSE IT AND THEN WHEN IT
HAPPENS THEY TRY TO SAY IT WON'T
BE THAT BAD.
THEN THEY REALIZE OH OH, WE'VE
GOT A PROBLEM SO THEN THEY TRY
TO FIND SOMEONE TO BLAME.
THAT PLACE PERSONS LIKE YOU
CAN'T BLAME ME.
THEY HAVE THEM OUT THERE SAYING
JOE BIDEN, WHAT HE WANTS MORE
THAN ANYTHING IS TO GET OUT IN
THE COUNTRY AND TRAVEL MORE AND
BE OUT THERE MORE.
I NEED TO TELL YOU SOMETHING.
NO POLITICAL OR POLICY PROBLEM
HAS EVER BEEN SOLVED IN THE
HISTORY OF THE WORLD WITH A
COMMUNICATIONS STRATEGY AND
CERTAINLY NOT BY SOMEBODY WHO
HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO ANSWER SO
FAR.
ON THE BABY FORMULA ONE,
SUSAN RICE IS THE DOMESTIC
POLICY CHAIRPERSON.
THEY WENT FOR A MONTH AND THEY
DIDN'T TELL HIM THIS WAS A
PROBLEM.
HE WENT OUT AND SAID IF WE WERE
MIND READERS.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE MIND
READERS.
YOU NEED COMPETENT STAFF.
>> Greg: WE ARE NOT MIND
READERS.
WE DON'T HAVE A SWITCH.
WE DON'T HAVE A DIAL.
IT'S NOT LIKE WE ARE ASKING YOU
TO BE ANY OF THOSE THINGS.
JUST DO THE RIGHT THING.
DO YOUR DAMN JOB OR GET OUT.
WHAT'S THE SCUTTLEBUTT?
THAT IS SLANG FOR GOSSIP.
THAT BIDEN IS SEETHING, HE IS
SEETHING BECAUSE HIS NUMBERS ARE
LOWER THAN TRUMP.
HE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE THE
ANTIDOTE TO TRUMP AND NOW HE IS
LESS POPULAR.
>> Judge Jeanine: HERE IS THE
AMAZING PART OF IT.
BEFORE WE GET TO THAT, I LOVE
THAT YOU ARE BACK, DANA.
>> Dana: IT IS NICE.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHO DID YOU
NOT LIKE?
>> Judge Jeanine: I JUST LOVE
DANA AND I WILL LEAVE IT AT
THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S AMAZING ABOUT
JOE BIDEN, HE THINKS OKAY, NOW
THAT HIS NUMBERS ARE WORSE THAN
DONALD TRUMP, HE THINKS HE'S
GOING TO BE ABLE TO GO OUT INTO
THE PUBLIC AND CONVINCE PEOPLE
THAT HE IS SHREWD, SMART,
CAPABLE OF TURNING IT AROUND.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT, JOE?
GET OUT THERE.
GO OUT THERE.
TALK TO PEOPLE IF YOU CAN.
PUT YOURSELF OUT THERE AND TRY
TO EXPLAIN TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WHY THE NUMBERS ARE SO
BAD.
WHY THERE IS SUCH A CULTURAL
DIVISION BETWEEN THE RIGHT AND
THE LEFT.
WHY 83% OF THE COUNTRY ARE NOT
ONLY READ ABOUT THE ECONOMY.
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF THIS COUNTRY.
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT THEIR
SAFETY, THEIR SECURITY.
THEY HAVE DOUBTS, FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
I DON'T REMEMBER READING ABOUT
THIS.
I JUST DON'T REMEMBER READING
ABOUT IT.
DOUBT IN THE NATION'S POLITICAL
SYSTEM?
DEMOCRATS HAVE SOON CRASHED THE
SYSTEM, WHETHER IT'S THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE, THE
SUPREME COURT SYSTEM, THE WHOLE
THING.
PEOPLE ARE LIKE, MAYBE AMERICA
ISN'T WHAT THEY SAID IT WAS AND
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO FIX IT.
>> Greg: JESSICA, IN THE GREEN
ROOM YOU SAID IF ONLY BIDEN HAD
CONCENTRATED ON REAL ISSUES THAN
THESE VIRTUE SIGNALING LOCUS AND
WE WOULDN'T HAVE THE WORST
PRESIDENT IN THE HISTORY OF THE
UNITED STATES.
I THOUGHT OF THAT WAS SO FRANK
AND HONEST.
CARE TO ELABORATE?
>> Jessica: IT REALLY WAS.
STAYS BETWEEN FRIENDS IN THE
GREEN ROOM.
TO THE JUDGE'S POINT ABOUT
EVERYONE THAT IS SCARED FOR THE
FUTURE OF DEMOCRACY, THE LAST
PRESIDENT TRYING TO OVERTURN AN
ELECTION RESULT AND DIDN'T MIND
OF HIS VICE PRESIDENT GOT HANGED
FOR IT.
IT IS HANGED.
OH, MY GOD.
SHE IS SITTING IN CHAPPAQUA WELL
AWARE SHE IS NOT THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
>> Greg: ARE YOU SURE THAT IS
HER?
>> Jessica: OH, MY GOD.
DEMOCRATS ARE FACING THE
POTENTIAL OF LOSING.
STATES THAT AT LEAST LEAN BLUE.
BRIGHT BLUE IS STILL GOING TO BE
FINE.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT CAN SERVE
A PURPOSE GOING AND TALKING TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE LIKELY TO VOTE
FOR DEMOCRATS OR COULD STILL BE
PERSUADED.
INDIVIDUAL CONGRESSMEN AND
SENATORS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT IF THEY WANT BIDEN
WITH THEM OR NOT, IF THAT MAKES
SENSE IN TERMS OF THEIR
DISTRICTS.
THE FRUSTRATION THAT'S GOING ON,
YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS.
SAYING CREATED OVER 8 MILLION
JOBS.
UNEMPLOYMENT.
WHY IS IT GOING SO POORLY?
I GET THE FRUSTRATION AND MAYBE
HIS STAFF SHOULD SAY WE HAVE A
FEW MONTHS TO FIX THIS.
LET IT GO.
HE WON THE 2020 ELECTION GOING
OUT THERE BY GETTING OUT THERE
ON THE TRAIL.
WHY ARE YOU LOOKING AT ME LIKE
THAT?
>> Judge Jeanine: HE WAS
PRETTY MUCH IN THE BASEMENT.
>> Jessica: THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
NOT TRUE.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, JESSE.
WRAP IT UP FOR US.
>> Jesse: MADE THE MISTAKE OF
TRYING TO SEPARATE THE ECONOMY
FROM INSULATION.
KEPT SAYING THE ECONOMY IS GREAT
BUT I FEEL YOUR PAIN WITH
INFLATION.
PERMISSION TO MAKE AN ANALOGY.
IT IS LIKE SAYING YOUR WIFE IS
REALLY HOT, I'M REALLY SORRY SHE
KEEPS CHEATING ON YOU.
YOU CAN'T SEPARATE THE TWO.
>> Greg: I TAKE BACK THE
PERMISSION.
>> Jesse: THE OTHER THING I --
HE DID, HE SAID THERE'S NOTHING
I CAN DO.
YOU CAN'T TELL THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THERE'S NOTHING I CAN DO
IF YOU ARE THE LEADER OF THE
FREE WORLD.
WE GAVE YOU THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE HOUSE, THE SENATE,
AIR FORCE ONE, THE TREASURY
DEPARTMENT, ALLIES.
>> Jessica: ALL THE NORMAL
STUFF.
>> Jesse: AND RECOVERED
ECONOMY AND NOW YOU SAY THERE'S
NOTHING YOU CAN DO?
COME ON.
NO ONE UNDERSTANDS THAT.
THEN HE SAYS YOU GET OUT THERE,
I'M GOING TO REENGINEER THE
ENTIRE U.S. ECONOMY AWAY FROM
FOSSIL FUELS AND LOWER THE
WORLD'S TEMPERATURE BUT I JUST
CAN'T LOWER THE PRICE OF GAS A
DOLLAR.
COME ON.
NOBODY BELIEVES ANY OF US.
HE SHOULD'VE FIRED THE FED
CHAIRMAN HE HAVE THE CHANCE LAST
TIME THIS TERM WAS UP.
DURING THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
HE RAISED RATES AND THEN FROZE
FOR THE FIRST YEAR OF THE BIDEN
TERM AND THEN DIDN'T DO ANYTHING
UNTIL IT WAS TOO LATE.
IT IS LIKE HIRING A DRUNK PILOT.
HE HAS ALREADY LOST CONTROL OF
THE PLANE.
DO YOU THINK HE IS GOING TO
STICK THE LANDING?
LASTLY, SEETHING ABOUT NOT BEING
ABLE TO GET OUT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE MORE.
YOU THINK BUSH OR CLINTON OR
OBAMA WOULD COMPLAIN THAT THEIR
STAFF WON'T LET THEM DO AN
EVENT?
THEY ARE FIRING UP THE JET AND
THEY ARE GOING SOMEWHERE.
GO TO A BABY FORMULA FACTORY,
ANYWHERE, GET OUT THERE.
REINFORCES THE PERCEPTION OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT THIS GUY IS
POWERLESS.
NOW HE IS TAKING A FOUR-DAY
WEEKEND.
HE WAS OFF FRIDAY, SATURDAY,
SUNDAY, OFF TODAY.
NO EVENTS.
HE IS NOT EVEN PLAYING GOLF LIKE
OTHER PRESIDENTS.
HE DOESN'T EVEN PLAY GOLF.
IT'S LIKE HE HAS GIVEN UP IN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE IT.
>> Greg: BECAUSE HE IS NOT
PLAYING GOLF.
>> Dana: THE COMPLAINT IS THAT
HE WANTS TO GO OUT INTO BABY
FORMULA EVENTS.
THAT'S NOT WHAT IT IS.
THEY WANT TO GO TO DELAWARE FOR
FOUR DAYS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
CRISIS.
>> Jesse: DELAWARE IS NOT A
SWING STATE.
>> Dana: 30 SECONDS LONGER.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT COULD STOP
DOING SO MANY EVENTS, STOP BEING
OUT THERE SO MUCH.
GOVERNMENT SHOULD NOT TRY TO
SOLVE EVERY SINGLE PROBLEM.
TAKE A STEP BACK.
THINK ABOUT THINGS FOR A MINUTE.
HAVE A COUPLE DAYS WHERE YOU ARE
THINKING AND THEN GO DO AN
EVENT.
DOING AN EVENT IS NOT HELPING
THEM AT THIS POINT.
>> Greg: WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO DO AN EVENT CALLED THE BREAK.
THAT'S NOT WHAT I WAS THINKING.
DISGUSTING.
WHAT WAS SHE DOING?
>> Jesse: THAT'S WHY SHE GOT
SUSPENDED.
SKI PARK THAT MA